Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur mittlerweile 25. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie rund um Themen der Raumfahrt und damit verwandter Bereiche. Und in solchen verwandten Bereich wird es heute gehen, der die Raumfahrt auch tangiert, auch wenn es sich hier im Wesentlichen um das Bedürfnis der Menschen auf der Erde betrifft. Konkret soll es gehen um das ZKI, das DLR. Dahinter verbirgt sich der schöne Name Zentrum für satellitengestützte Kriseninformation oder auch Kriseninformationszentrum, wie man auch möchte. Und dazu begrüße ich als Gesprächspartner heute Tobias Schneiderhahn. Du bist hier wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter beim DLR und dem ZKI zugeteilt, zugeschlagen. Ich weiß nicht, muss man sich da bewerben? Wird man da, landet man da, wird man da hinten versetzt?
Ja, das ist ein großes Missverständnis, würde ich mal sagen. Viele bewerben sich tatsächlich oder für das ZKI. Das ZKI aber selbst ist eigentlich ein Service. Man müsste sich für unser Institut in irgendeine Abteilung bewerben, speziell in unsere Abteilung, weil wir uns im ZKI speziell aus dieser Abteilung rekrutieren. Und die Abteilung ist zuständig für zivile Kriseninformation und Georisiken.
Und welches Institut steckt dahinter?
Das Deutsche Fernerkundungsdatenzentrum. Und das ist ein Partnerinstitut zusammen mit dem Institut für Methodik der Fernerkundung. Und beide bilden das Earth Observation Center oder Erdbeobachtungszentrum, EUC.
Über Erdbeobachtung war ja hier auch schon mal die Rede aus demselben Gebäude auch herausgesprochen mit dem Jochen Lotz-Even. Da ging es um allerlei Aspekte, wie man von oben auf die Erde schauen kann, welche Daten dort zu gewinnen sind. Da klang, wie auch in vielen anderen Podcasts auch nebenbei an, dass es das ZKI gibt. Und auch Teile der Aktivitäten wurden da auch schon besprochen. Aber wir wollen ja heute mal ganz konkret einsteigen, was das ZKI nun so tut und wie es das vor allem so tut. Beziehungsweise, jetzt sage ich immer das ZKI, als wäre es ein Institut. Also bleiben wir bei der Sprachregelung. Es handelt sich hier um eine Dienstleistung des DLR. Aber vielleicht, bevor wir da voll einsteigen, kurz nochmal so zu deinem persönlichen Werdegang. Was hast du denn so für eine Ausbildungsrichtung genommen, dass du dann beim DLR gelandet bist?
Ich habe Geografie studiert, hier in München. Wir haben auch sehr viele Geografen, weil im ZKI es sehr wichtig ist, dass man Zusammenhänge sehr schnell erkennen kann. Das ist eine Spezialität des geografischen Studiengangs. Danach habe ich dann im Bereich Fernerkundung promoviert, habe Radarszenen analysiert, habe Windfelder abgeleitet, habe Windfelder untersucht in der Umgebung von Offshore-Plattformen, also Windanlagen im Meer. Danach bin ich dann direkt Januar 2006 ans ZKI bzw. in unsere Abteilung gekommen, ans DfD.
Das ZKI selber gibt es etwas länger, seit 2004?
Genau, 2004 wurde es gegründet, wobei das ZKI schon Erfahrungen in den Jahren davor mit Krisenanfragen gemacht hat, sowohl national als auch international, sodass das ZKI insgesamt auf eine mehr als zehnjährige Erfahrung zurückblicken kann.
Wie muss man das verstehen? Also 10 Jahre, das heißt, diese Art des Datenbedarfs gab es auch schon vorher, es gab bloß nicht so eine klar definierte Struktur, die darauf antwortet?
Genau, also die Erdbeobachtung insgesamt ist natürlich schon viel älter. Wenn man jetzt die Ziele eines Services wie das ZKIs anschaut, ist es die schnelle Datenbereitstellung. Es entsteht irgendwo eine Krise, eine Notlage, eine Naturkatastrophe ereignet sich und man muss so schnell wie möglich Informationen darüber haben, wie groß ist das Ereignis, wo treten die Schäden tatsächlich auf. Und das heißt, man muss nicht nur am Ende schnell arbeiten können in der Analyse, man muss die Daten auch schnell haben. Und die Erdbeobachtung an sich war natürlich eher ausgerichtet auf langfristige Beobachtungen, wie atmosphärische Veränderungen, Klimawandel, so etwas, aber nicht darauf ausgerichtet, möglichst schnell die Daten aufzunehmen und downzulinken. Es ist ja auch so, dass vor allem in dem hochauflösenden Bereich, ich sag mal im zehn Meter oder feiner für einen Bildpunkt, da nehmen die Sensoren gar nicht oder die Mission gar nicht regelmäßig auf, sondern man muss ihnen vorher immer sagen, wo sie aufnehmen sollen. Das kann ich ihnen natürlich erst sagen, wenn ich weiß, wo die Krise stattgefunden hat. Und von daher waren die Systeme vorher gar nicht auf diese schnelle Reaktion ausgerichtet, vom Satellitensegment wie vom Bodensegment und auch anschließend dann nicht. Und das hat sich die Jahre über aus entwickelt. Ein Beispiel ist auch 1999 hat sich die International Charter Space and Major Disasters gegründet, ein Zusammenschluss von Raumfahrtagenturen, die genau dieses zum Ziel hatten, möglichst schnell im Fall von Naturkatastrophen Daten bereitzustellen. Und so hat sich das dann nach und nach entwickelt. Also die letzten 10, 15 Jahre ist genau dieses Thema sehr schnell vorangeschritten.
Also um es nochmal knapper zusammenzufassen, ZKI ist einfach ein Zentrum, eine zentralisierte Serviceeinheit beim DLR, die dafür eingerichtet wurde, um im Krisenfalle, und Krisen heißt jetzt sowas wie Erdbeben, Tsunamis, Waldbrände, Überflutungen, also wirklich so diese großen Naturkatastrophen, also meistens durch die Natur ausgelöst, weiß ja gar ja was noch für Katastrophen in Zukunft dazukommen, aber wo einfach klar ist, große Mengen an Material, Menschen, etc., müssen bewegt werden, müssen koordiniert werden, und um das effektiv zu tun, muss man vor allem Informationen darüber haben, was ist eigentlich passiert, wo ist was passiert, wie ist die Lage. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Genau, also das ZKI hat natürlich noch weitere Ziele, nicht nur die schnelle Krisenreaktion, sondern die Idee ist, den gesamten Krisenzyklus abzudecken. Wenn man sich das wie eine Uhr vorstellt und bei 12 Uhr die tatsächliche Krise, diese Naturereignung, stattfindet, dann kommt die schnelle Hilfe erst, dann der Wiederaufbau und dann geht es schon wieder über in die Vorbereitung, Preparedness-Phase und wieder zur Early-Wohnung, also der schnellen Frühwarnung. Und dann ist man wieder oben bei der 12 Uhr oder bei der 12 Uhr, wo dann das nächste Ereignis eintritt. Und die Idee ist natürlich, Dienstleistungen über den gesamten Krisenzyklus hinweg anbieten zu können. Und ein gutes Beispiel ist auch das GITUES-Projekt, in dessen Rahmen wir auch als ZKI, als DLR, mit noch anderen Projektpartnern das Frühwarnsystem, das Tsunami-Frühwarnsystem, für Indonesien aufgebaut haben. Das ist allerdings jetzt nichts, was rein DLR ist, sondern da waren wir ein Partner. Aber das zeigt, dass wir auch schon andere Teile mit abdecken. Und die...
Wie heißt das Projekt noch mal? Also das ist dieses Tsunami-Frühwarnungssystem.
Genau, TUS steht für Tsunami Early Warning System. Und von daher weiten sich die Gebiete immer weiter aus, wobei man klar sagen muss, der Schwerpunkt im Moment ist noch die Notfallkartierung.
Das heißt, das ZKI ist auch quasi 24 Stunden im Betrieb? Das ist immer ansprechbar.
Genau, also wir haben einen 24-7-Service. Wir haben eine Hotline. Man kann uns jederzeit erreichen, jederzeit wird reagiert. Es ist aber nicht so, dass wir 24 Stunden durcharbeiten. Das heißt, wir haben ein Team von Kollegen und Kolleginnen, die tagsüber anstelle des Büros dann in den Krisenraum gehen und dort Aktivierung abarbeiten oder Turnusaufgaben erledigen. Und wenn nichts zu tun ist, gehen die auch ganz normal heim. Und wenn eine Krisenkartierung ist, haben wir eine Rufbereitschaft. Und dann wird, wenn fertig gearbeitet werden muss, wird dann bis spät in die Nacht gearbeitet oder auch in der Nacht reingekommen ins ZKI. Also von daher decken wir mit der Rufbereitschaft dann wie im Krankenhaus die volle 24 Stunden.
Genau, das wollte ich auch gerade sagen, so wie Bereitschaftsdienst bei den Ärzten. Wenn was ist, macht es Piep-Piep und dann muss man auch raus aus dem Bett. Und dann gibt es eine entsprechende Verfügbarkeit, wer jetzt quasi der Erste ist, der aufstehen muss.
Gutes Beispiel ist jetzt, wir haben einen vollen Anruf von dem deutschen Nutzer, bekommen dem Gemeinschaftlichen Meldezentrum für Bund und Länder, dem GMLZ, die die Endnutzer Anfragen zu bündeln. Und die haben jetzt ausgelöst fürs THW. Das heißt, wir werden ziemlich sicher dieses Wochenende für das THW dann Karten erstellen.
Weil wieder irgendwas Schlimmes passiert ist?
Ja, es muss nicht immer eine Naturkatastrophe dahinterstecken. Manchmal ist auch einfach die Dringlichkeit der Anfrage ausschlaggebend. Im Moment ist in Ostafrika mit der Dürre und den Bevölkerungswanderungen eine sehr, sehr knifflige Lage. Und das THW ist dort vor Ort in mehreren Flüchtlingslagern aktiv und möchte, weil sich dort gerade so viel bewegt, immer wieder ein Update haben, immer wieder die neuesten Informationen haben, wo sind die Flüchtlingsströme, wie entwickeln sich die Lager, in denen sie aktiv sind, auch um die Lager besser managen zu können.
Und diese Flüchtlingsströme lassen sich mit Satelliten beobachten?
Die Flüchtlingsströme nicht. Wir machen in erster Linie ein Camp-Monitoring. Das heißt, wir nehmen sehr hochauflösende Bilder von den Camps auf und können dann zum Beispiel die Entwicklung der Camps darstellen, wo sie kleiner geworden sind, wo sie größer geworden sind. Im Notfall können wir bis runtergehen, einzelne Hütten zählen, einzelne Personen. Das ist für die Schnelle der Zeit dann meistens nicht auch nicht gewünscht, sondern es geht in erster Linie darum...
Um Fluss-Abfluss zu messen und daran messen zu können, was Sache ist.
Es ist ja auch so, dass man, wir arbeiten da auch eng mit der UN zum Beispiel zusammen, die solche Camps dann über Jahre auch betreiben. Und man muss das Camp auch was sanitäre Einrichtungen angeht und Verpflegungsstationen natürlich optimal ausrichten. Das heißt, man muss sicherstellen, dass nicht gewisse Bereiche eines Camps unterversorgt sind. Und dazu ist es ganz gut, wenn man weiß, in welche Richtung sich die Lager entwickeln. Aber wir machen auch zusätzliche Analysen, wie eine Umfeldanalyse. Flüchtlingslager können extrem groß sein, zum Teil bis zu mehreren hunderttausend Einwohnern. Das ist fast unvorstellbar. Die brauchen aber auch natürlich Material. Und viele Flüchtlinge, die dort wohnen, gehen einfach ins Umfeld und holen sich Brennholz. Das heißt, wir machen so eine Art Vegetationsmonitoring, wie sich die Umgebung verhält, wie weit muss man gehen, um zum nächsten Brennholz zu kommen? Ist es überhaupt noch machbar?
Sind die Ressourcen überhaupt noch vorhanden, etc.?
Genau.
Das ist ja eigentlich, könnte man ja sagen, das ist ja allein schon wahrscheinlich ausreichend, um eigentlich 24-7 Bericht zu erstatten, oder?
Ja, wobei die Anfragen im Moment noch sehr, ich sag mal, spärlich sind. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass UNHCR für jedes Camp, das sie betreiben, dann ständig auf uns zu kommen und sagen, wir brauchen da jetzt Karten. Insgesamt ist diese Art der Informationsbereitstellung immer noch ein bisschen in den, steckt noch in den Kinderschuhen. Die meisten Hilfsorganisationen haben über Jahrzehnte mit konventionellen Methoden gearbeitet. Und allein das Bewusstsein, dass sie, wenn sie, ich sag mal, 10.000 Euro in Satellitendaten stecken und die Analyse dazu, sich auf der anderen Seite vielleicht 50.000 Euro in Zelt und Verpflegung dann sparen, das ist noch nicht ganz durchgedrungen.
Das heißt, das muss man auch noch dazu sagen, das Ganze ist jetzt nicht unbedingt immer kostenlos.
Ja, also bisher hatten wir das immer über Forschungsprojekte abgedeckt, weil es eben noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt. Man muss ja nicht nur das Bewusstsein beim Nutzer schaffen, dass es neue Technologien gibt, die er zu seinem Vorteil einsetzen kann. Es ist ja auch so, dass es eine sehr große Bandbreite an möglichen Nutzungsarten gibt, für die man erstmal auch validierte Methoden vorhalten muss. Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was ein sehr langwieriger Prozess ist.
Versuchen wir das mal so ein bisschen auseinander zu flechten. Da war ja noch eine ganze Menge drin. Vielleicht erstmal so die generelle Struktur nochmal. Also das ZKI ist hier angesiedelt, wir haben es auch noch gar nicht gesagt, in Oberpfaffenhofen auf dem entsprechenden DLR-Gelände, angedockt an das Erdbeobachtungszentrum, das Observation Center, EOC, wo wir jetzt uns auch gerade drin befinden. Und ja, auf die schon beschriebene Art und Weise ist man ansprechbar, es passiert was, es gibt irgendwie eine Anfrage, dann wird entsprechend reagiert. Wer stellt denn diese Anfragen? Also da kann ja jetzt nicht jeder kommen und potenziell gibt es aber viele Interessenten. Jetzt hast du es schon angedeutet, es gibt zumindest hier eine Bündelung, schon mal so auf Bundes- und Länderebene, durch dieses, wie heißt das nochmal, Melde?
Gemeinschaftliches Melde- und Lagezentrum für Bund und Länder. Aber das ist wirklich nur der eine Nutzer für Deutschland, der autorisierte Nutzer. Es hängt vielmehr an den unterschiedlichen Auslösemechanismen. Also es gibt, wie schon mal kurz erwähnt, die International Charter Space and Major Disasters. Die hatten einen bestimmten Kreis von autorisierten Nutzern, den sie sich über Jahre aufgebaut hat. Das hängt in erster Linie an den Mitgliedsstaaten, die sich an der Charter beteiligen. Da ist Deutschland natürlich auch mit dabei. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel das Projekt SAFER, Emergency Response Service der Europäischen Kommission, das finanziert wird durch die Kommission und die einzelnen Mitgliedsstaaten auch die Möglichkeit haben, diesen Service auszulösen. Das deckt dann die komplette Bandbreite ab, von Möglichkeit auszulösen bis hin zur Datenbereitstellung, die Value-Adding-Services wie das ZKI, also die Analysemöglichkeiten und dann die Auslieferung der Produkte. Also da ist man dann im All-Inclusive-Service sozusagen.
Wer sind denn dann die Nutzer von dem International Charter? Sind das dann direkt die Nationalstaaten und dann geht es nochmal durch oder können dann auch so Organisationen wie Rote Kreuz oder wer auch immer dort Anfragen stellen?
Theoretisch können auch andere Endnutzer Anfragen stellen. Das Problem ist, die Anfrage muss immer über einen autorisierten Nutzer an die Charter geschleust werden, weil wirklich die Charter auslösen dürfen, nur die autorisierten Nutzer. Und diese autorisierten Nutzer, das sind ja Einrichtungen oder Behörden in diesen Staaten. Normalerweise sind es die Zivilschutzbehörden, manchmal ist es im Innenministerium, manchmal im Außenministerium aufgehängt. Das hängt dann von dem Staat ab, der in der Charter mit vertreten ist.
Und ist da jeder Staat irgendwie mit vertreten?
Es ist die ganze Welt abgedeckt, zumindest über sogenannte Cooperative Buddies, das sind vor allem die UN. Das heißt, jedes Land, in dem auch ein UN-Büro vertreten ist, kann über sein UN-Büro dann die Charter auslösen.
Das heißt, das wäre sozusagen der Last Resort. Wenn man nicht über ein eigenes Institut oder Organisation verfügt, die ohnehin schon dort registriert ist, dann kann man auf jeden Fall zur UN gehen und sagen, hier Krise, Katastrophe, Hilfe, Hilfe, wir brauchen Unterstützung. Und dann wird es dadurch ausgelöst.
Genau.
Und ausgelöst heißt jetzt auch wirklich, es muss sehr schnell gehen.
Genau. Also die Zielsetzung ist, so schnell wie möglich Daten bereitzustellen in der International Charter. Die Charter selbst ist ein Verbund von Raumfahrtagenturen, die gesagt haben, wenn eine Naturkatastrophe passiert, bündeln wir unsere Ressourcen, werfen quasi unsere ganzen Satellitmissionen in einen Topf und schauen, dass wir so schnell wie möglich über dem Gebiet eine Aufnahme erreichen und die dann für eine Analyse bereitstellen. Das kann sein, dass die Satellitendaten direkt an den Endnutzer gehen, wenn er die Fähigkeit besitzt, die Daten selbst auszuwerten, oder dass es an ein Value-Added geht, an ein Projekt, das sagt, okay, für diesen Fall kann ich die Auswertung übernehmen. Und die Erfahrung zeigt, dass der Mechanismus der Charter ein sehr effektiver Mechanismus ist. Und das DLR selbst ist ja auch im Oktober letzten Jahres der Charter beigetreten, ist also Vollmitglied, wo wir unsere Ressourcen, Satellitenressourcen, den TerraSatX und TandemX eben bereitstellen. Und da möglichst schnell Radeaufnahmen zur Verfügung stellen. Radeaufnahmen haben die schöne Eigenschaft, dass sie nicht auf die optischen Signale gehen, sondern auf Oberflächenrauchigkeiten und damit in einem anderen Wellenlängenbereich agieren. Und durch diese längere Wellenlänge können sie durch Wolken durchschauen.
Also sie sind von dem Wetter nicht mehr in dem Maße abhängig, wie das jetzt optische Beobachtung wäre.
Und das zweite ist ein System, das selber aktiv beleuchtet und damit von den Beleuchtungsverhältnissen nicht abhängig ist. Das heißt, wir können eigentlich zu jedem technisch möglichen Zeitpunkt auch eine Aufnahme von der Erdoberfläche bekommen. Und das Radarsignal ist dann noch empfindlich auf Oberflächenrauchigkeiten. Und die Rauchigkeit ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich von Land-zu-Wasser-Oberfläche. Damit kann ich eine sehr schöne Differenzierung oder eine Abgrenzung von Land-zu-Wasser-Oberflächen machen. In Überflutungsfällen, die von der Statistik her 50 Prozent aller Anfragen darstellen, ist das natürlich dann das Mittel der Wahl.
Das heißt, da ist dann tatsächlich auch diese Satellitenkombination die beste Wahl? Ja, aber TerraSat, Tandem X sollte man vielleicht an der Stelle noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen. Das ist ja ein relativ neues Projekt, was erst vor kurzem gestartet wurde, beziehungsweise vor allem erst vor kurzem in diesen speziellen Tandem-Modus gegangen ist, also ein Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten-Pärchen, die koordiniert gemeinsam mehr oder weniger dieselbe Flugbahn fliegen, aber in einem definierten Abstand zueinander, dann an den Polen, glaube ich, ihren Weg kreuzen.
Also sie haben eine leicht geneigte Umlaufbahn, also es ist eine nahe polare Umlaufbahn. Insgesamt ist die Flugformation eine Helix, also die sind leicht miteinander versetzt und damit sieht es, wenn man sie im Flug beobachtet, aus, als ob die sich umeinander drehen. Diese Konstellation ist was ganz besonderes und technisch sehr aufwendig, auch in der Auswertung. Für unsere Zwecke ist diese Formation nicht zwingend notwendig, weil wir eigentlich nur eine Aufnahme von einem der beiden Satelliten brauchen. Wir brauchen jetzt nicht beide Kapazitäten, weil die Mission ist dafür in erster Linie ausgerichtet, um ein weltweites Höhenmodell zu generieren, mit einer Auflösungsstufe, die so noch nicht verfügbar ist und wird damit auch einen neuen Standard setzen. Für unsere Analyse brauchen wir einfach nur ein einzelnes Bild und kein Bildpaar. Wir brauchen insofern doch ein Bildpaar, nicht gleichzeitig aufgenommen oder nahezu gleichzeitig, sondern ein Bild vor der Katastrophe und ein Bild nach der Katastrophe. Das ist immer ganz praktisch, weil man dann eben vorher mit nachher vergleichen kann. Man hat einen Normalzustand und einen Jetztzustand und kann sagen, das ist eigentlich der normale Flusslauf und da ist jetzt noch überall Wasser mehr.
Aber kann man nicht mit der Höheninformation dann auch tatsächlich so die Höhe der Überflutung auch tatsächlich messen oder ist das jetzt so eine Information, die man gar nicht braucht im Krisenfall?
Brauchen? Tut man die schon.
Kann man die auch so schnell gewinnen?
Das ist der Punkt. Also es ist nicht ganz trivial. Man braucht dann noch zusätzliche Informationen, die man mit einbauen muss. Man braucht eben sehr genaues Höhenmodell. Man muss das Bild, quasi das zweite Bild in das Höhenmodell einfügen können. Und man braucht dann auch eine gewisse Modellierfähigkeit. Und das ist noch eine Sache, an der wir auch dran sind, die aber aufgrund der Datenlage nicht immer möglich ist.
Also es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass das auch tatsächlich dann mal so käme, dass man wirklich die Tandem-Informationen auswertet, also beide Blickwinkel auswertet, um dann auch die korrekte Höhe in die Gesamtberichterstattung mit einzubauen. Aber derzeit geht es vor allem erst mal, ist da Wasser oder ist da kein Wasser?
Ja, man muss auch das noch mal womöglich geografisch unterscheiden. Also wenn man außerhalb von Europa ist, also der Unterschied Europa außerhalb Europa ist, Europa ist relativ weit entwickelt. Da hat man auch sehr gute Geodaten, da brauche ich keine, brauche ich nicht zwingend, sage ich mal, ein Tandem-Modell. Da habe ich womöglich aus flugzeuggetragenen Systemen schon viel höher auflösende Höhenmodelle. Wenn ich aber nach Afrika schaue oder Südamerika, da macht es dann durchaus Sinn, solche Modelle zur Anwendung zu bringen, zumindest für uns im Service. Da sind es aber dann mehr Flächenfluten, wo die Höheninformation, zumindest die Überflutungshöhe, keine so große Bedeutung mehr hat. Da macht es fast mehr Sinn, zu schauen, wie lang stand da Wasser über die Zeit, weil man dann natürlich gewisse Epidemien hat, die sich daran anschließen, wenn ich da Wasser lange stehen habe.
Die zeitliche Variable an der Stelle. Und das fließt aber auch alles mit ein in die Berichterstattung. Wenn jetzt diese Anfrage kommt, wie konkret ist denn diese Anfrage? Also wird ganz konkret nach bestimmten Daten angefragt oder ganz konkret nach bestimmten Bereichen? Oder wird einfach nur gesagt, hier Katastrophe, Pakistan, liefert uns mal alles, was irgendwie geht. Und wir gucken dann selber mal, was wir damit anfangen können. Oder ist das schon, dass man wirklich sagt, wir brauchen jetzt hier ganz konkret eine Information, um das, das, das und das abschätzen zu können. Und dann wird auch nur diese Information übermittelt. Was wird gefragt, was geht zurück?
Wieder ganz unterschiedlich. Also bei der Charter ist es normalerweise so, dass einfach nur ein Ereignis passiert und der Nutzer sagt, ich brauch dafür Daten. Man weiß inzwischen, was normalerweise bei was für eine Katastrophe dann an Informationen letzten Endes gesucht ist. Wir haben aber auch, wie gesagt, dieses Safer-Projekt auf europäischer Ebene. Da ist nicht nur das Ziel gewesen, diesen Service auf operationelle Beine zu stellen, sondern man hat die ganze Kette standardisiert, verbessert, operationalisiert. Und ein Element davon ist auch sozusagen ein Bestellformular, ein Auslöseformular, wo der Nutzer bestimmte Sachen angeben muss. Zum Beispiel den Desaster-Typ, aber er kann auch schon gewisse Produkte ankreuzen. Das heißt, das Projekt hat schon ein Produktportfolio entwickelt für gewisse Desaster-Typen. Und der Nutzer kann sich das Portfolio anschauen, kann sagen, okay, das kann ich brauchen, das kann ich brauchen. Er kreuzt es nur noch an und am Ende kriegt er genau das, was er angekreuzt hat, auch geliefert.
Ein Krisen-Kaufhaus.
In etwa, ja.
Was für Katastrophentypen werden denn unterschieden?
Erdbeben, Flut, Feuer, Landslides, der Richtung. Also von der Natur Ereignis, ja.
Und was für unterschiedliche Daten, Produkte, können jetzt da jeweils geliefert werden? Ist das jetzt eine unendliche Zahl?
Nein, das sind im Moment fünf verschiedene Produkttypen, zumindest für die schnelle Kriseninformation. Das ist eine Referenzkarte. Das ist für Europa weniger interessant, weil man da normalerweise eine gute Kartenlage hat. Aber für Afrika ist es manchmal ganz praktisch, dass man erst mal guckt, wie ist die Lage insgesamt? Also wie sieht es vor Ort überhaupt aus? Dazu kann man ein Archivbild nehmen. Und dann gibt es die Krisenprodukte. Das ist ein, wir nennen es Disaster Extent, einfach mal das Ausmaß. Und dann kommt das Damage Assessment, dass dann dieses Ausmaß schon kombiniert mit den, ich sag mal, mit den Werten, die vorhanden sind. Dass man sagt, okay, dieses Gebiet ist stärker betroffen. Oder diese Stadt, wenn ich jetzt ein Erdbeben habe, dieser Stadtteil, der ist zu 100 Prozent beschädigt. Dieser Stadtteil, der ist eigentlich noch vollkommen intakt. Sodass die Helfer vor Ort schon ihre Kapazitäten zielgerichteter einsetzen können. Und dann gibt es jetzt noch zusätzlich zwei weitere Produkte. Das eine ist das Bevölkerungsprodukt. Da kann man anfragen, wie groß die Anzahl der Bevölkerung ist, die von dem Ereignis betroffen ist. Das ist natürlich auch in der Schnelle der Zeit erst mal so eine Daumengröße, die sich dann über die Zeit auch verfeinert. Aber das hilft den vor allem so Organisationen wie World Food Program einzuschätzen, wie viel Hilfsmittel müssen dorthin transportiert werden. Also gerade dieser Logistik-Aspekt ist sehr wichtig. Und das fünfte Produkt sind dann Evakuierungspläne, was auch nicht immer relevant ist. Deshalb hat man eben die Möglichkeit, sich unter den Produkten eins auszuwählen oder mehrere.
Wenn jetzt so eine Anfrage reingekommen ist, das hat ja auch alles so ein bisschen was von Feuerwehr. Ja, hat man so gleich so dieses Bild im Kopf, so mit Rutschstange und so weiter, die gibt es hier soweit ich weiß nicht. Aber trotzdem muss man ja dann in dem Falle, muss es ja nicht nur jetzt jemanden geben, dem man so aus dem Bett klingelt, sondern es muss ja dann auch irgendwie mehr oder weniger klar verteilt sein, wer kümmert sich jetzt um was. Wie ist denn das, ist das strukturiert? Und wenn ja, wie ist das strukturiert? Oder spricht man sich dann immer so ab, je nachdem wer jetzt so gerade da ist, wer sich dann um was kümmert?
Also auf dem Level, auf dem das ZKI arbeitet, läuft das nicht mehr auf Zuhuf, sondern das muss schon sehr gut strukturiert und organisiert sein. Wir haben ein Rollenmodell eingeführt. Wir haben fünf verschiedene Rollen im ZKI, den Erstkontakt, also den Rapid Mapping Coordinator. Wir haben dann den Activation Manager, der koordiniert dann die Kartierungsaktivitäten. Wir haben einen Bildverarbeiter, einen Geoinformationsexperten und noch einen Datenmanager. Das sind die fünf Rollen. Und diese sind kontinuierlich besetzt. Und gespeist werden diese fünf Rollen eben in erster Linie aus der einen Abteilung zivile Kriseninformation und Georisiken. Das heißt, wir haben einen Pool von ungefähr 23, 24 Leuten, die dann in dem Rotationsmechanismus diese Rollen belegen.
23 Leute, fünf Rollen. Aber was heißt jetzt Erstkontakt? Der Erskontakt ist derjenige, der die Anfrage entgegennimmt.
Genau.
Ist das dann derjenige, der dann auch den weiteren Kontakt hält?
Zumindest nicht beim ZKI, bei anderen Service-Providern mag das dann anders geregelt sein. Bei uns ist es so, dass der Erstkontakt die E-Mails ständig im Auge behält vom ZKI und auch das Krisentelefon in der Hand hält, wovon die Nummer an die ganzen Nutzer verteilt ist und an die ganzen Mechanismen. Und dort gehen die Anfragen dann ein und es findet hier eine Erste.
Der steht ständig unter Strom.
Und die anderen, die können, ich sag mal noch, so ein bisschen in Wartepositionen verbleiben. Und wenn dann klar ist, die Aktivierung kommt ans ZKI, dann werden die anderen Rollen aktiviert. Und wir haben da immer noch im Moment zumindest noch eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit, weil dann erst noch die Daten bestellt werden müssen. Dann müssen die Satelliten getaskt werden. Das heißt, die müssen programmiert werden. Dazu muss man warten, bis man überhaupt erst mal in den Empfangsbereich von den Satelliten kommt. Dann müssen die drüber fliegen, müssen aufnehmen. Die Daten müssen runtergespielt werden, wieder prozessiert werden. Und dann schlagen sie bei uns im ZKI.
Spielen wir das doch vielleicht mal so durch. Oder vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein gutes Beispiel, woran man das konkret festmachen kann. Mir fällt natürlich jetzt hier gleich der Tsunami in Japan ein, der ja hier sicherlich auch für ordentlich Beschäftigung gesorgt hat. Erdbeben haben ja überhaupt auch so, das sind ja so Krisen, die sind halt zehn Minuten vorher nicht da gewesen. Von daher gibt es ja dann so einen sehr klar definierten Startpunkt. Wie lange hat es denn gedauert, bis der japanische Tsunami hier im ZKI aufgeschlagen ist?
Ich glaube, eine Viertelstunde. Also es war extrem schnell.
Viertelstunde nach dem Erdbeben oder eine Viertelstunde nach dem Tsunami?
Viertelstunde nach dem Erdbeben.
Nach dem Erdbeben.
Da haben wir einen Anruf bekommen, dass es jetzt was Schlimmeres gibt.
Und wer hat da angerufen?
Das war ein Vertreter aus dem japanischen Parlament. Das hatte sich glaube ich zu dem Zeitpunkt sogar gerade getagt. Und dann hat es gerappelt und dann wurden sofort von dort Mechanismen angestoßen.
Aus dem Parlament? Also wir reden jetzt von normalen Abgeordneten.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer das dann genau ist. Japan ist ja selber Mitglied in dieser Charter, durch das sie mit der japanischen Raumfahrtbehörde Mitglied ist. Daher sind die ganz gut vernetzt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der Name von dem Kollegen hieß, der dann ausgelöst hat, aber wir wussten nach 15 Minuten, dass wir als ZKI aktiv werden müssen.
Wie konkret war dann die Anfrage? Also hieß das nur, haltet euch warm, wir brauchen Daten. Oder war schon klar zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich weiß nicht, wie lange hat es gedauert mit dem Tsunami?
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau.
Nach dem Erdbeben?
Eine Stunde, zwei, bis der reingelaufen ist. Also das Erdbebenzentrum war ziemlich nah vor der Küste.
Okay, also das heißt, im ZKI wusste man schon, es gibt was zu tun, bevor das mit dem Tsunami sich überhaupt so in dem Maße abgezeichnet hat. Es war einfach Erdbeben und Dinge sind passiert.
Es ist natürlich eine andere Katastrophe. Also wenn jemand wegen Erdbeben anruft, dann werden andere Sensoren getaskt, als wenn ich für einen Tsunami anrufe.
Aber in Japan hat man das natürlich doch mal gleich im Hinterkopf, oder?
Hm, nicht zwingend. Also wenn das Erdbeben, ich sag mal, auf Land passiert und es ist wirklich nur eine Stadt betroffen, dann weiß ich ganz genau, wir müssen Richtung Damage Assessment gehen, wir müssen gucken, wie viele Häuser sind eingestürzt. Und wenn ich einen Tsunami hab, dann muss ich natürlich womöglich einen viel längeren Streifen Küste beobachten mit einer anderen Auflösung und mit einem ganz anderen Abstimmungsmodell.
Das heißt, diese Anfrage war zunächst einmal nur Erdbeben an sich, man wusste auch noch gar nicht, wo das Erdbeben war, oder weiß man das dann auch schon?
Das weiß man relativ genau.
Wo kommt diese Information her?
Da gibt es verschiedene Zentren, eins über das GFZ, Geoforschungszentrum in Potsdam, die haben ein ganz gutes Modell, USGS, das sind die Amerikaner, die haben auch ein ganz gutes Modell.
Was heißt, die haben ein gutes Modell? Müssen die da nicht konkrete Sensoren haben? Wer erfasst diese Information, wer vermag das überhaupt so schnell zu verorten, wo ein Erdbeben jetzt sein Zentrum hat?
Es sind natürlich verschiedene Sensoren global verteilt. Letzten Endes ist es aber auch ja nur eine indirekte Information. Also man muss dann schon, ich sag mal auch, in gewisser Form modellieren, wo dann tatsächlich das EPI-Zentrum ist.
Das heißt, verschiedene Sensoren liefern mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit Daten ab. Und man merkt, oh, hier gibt es Bewegung. Das wurde von diesen 10, 20 Sensoren gemessen. Und dann fließt das sofort in so ein Modell ein, in ein mathematisches Modell und aus dem kommt dann raus, also das sieht aus wie ein Erdbeben, der und der Stärke und vermutlich lag es dort.
Ja, das Erdbeben findet ja irgendwo zwischen den Sensoren statt, geografisch gesehen und auch in einer unterschiedlichen Tiefe. Und von daher muss das schon irgendwo auch berechnet werden.
Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt der Warnung war eigentlich schon klar, Erdbeben vor Japan.
Genau. Und wir haben dann alles in Bewegung gesetzt, haben dann auch über die Charter dann schon relativ schnell Daten bekommen.
Wie konkret war denn jetzt die Anfrage? Also was wollte man wissen? Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, erstmal hat so die Erdbeben-Lampe geleuchtet. Das heißt, man musste schnell in dieses Vorher-Nachher-Ding reingehen. Aber von Japan gibt es ja wahrscheinlich ziemlich genaue Daten und Karten schon.
Ja, man muss da auch immer noch ein bisschen aufpassen, man kommt nicht immer an alle Informationen dann zu dem Zeitpunkt auch ran. In der Charta ist es so, dass man natürlich versucht, zum Beispiel das Projektmanagement und auch das Value-Adding möglichst nah an die Katastrophe zu legen, sodass man keinen Verlust hat über Zeitverschiebung zum Beispiel. Es macht keinen Sinn, wenn ich den Projektmanager, der die Daten dann einsammelt und kontrolliert aus den ganzen verschiedenen Raumfahrten, der Charta, und die dann wieder an den Nutzer weitergibt oder an die Value-Adding-Agentur, der sollte ja nicht so weit weg sein. Wenn ich da immer acht Stunden Zeitversatz habe, dann habe ich echt ein Kommunikationsproblem. Und wenn ich es aber zu nah an den Ort bringe, zum Beispiel an die Zivilschutzbehörde, die betroffen ist, dann kann es sein, dass die alles andere zu tun hat, als sich um Satellitendaten zu kümmern und die zu koordinieren. Von daher ist es immer ein bisschen so eine Abwägung, wo kann man das am besten platzieren. Und dann grundsätzlich ist Japan natürlich gut abgedeckt für die Japaner selbst. Wenn die dann ihr Value-Adding auch selber machen können, ist alles gut. In dem Fall war es aber so, dass sie mit der Größe des Ereignisses vollkommen überfordert waren. Und sie hatten auch bis eine Woche später noch kein so richtig klares Bild, wo sind die Schäden wie hoch. Von daher war es schon gut, dass da auch zum Teil mehrere Organisationen parallel auch kartiert haben, umzusehen. Wir haben dann diesen Teil abgedeckt, die anderen haben sie im Küstenteil weiter nördlich vorgenommen. Man kann zum Teil auch dann die Ergebnisse miteinander vergleichen, ob das ungefähr hinkommt von der Schadenserfassung her. Und im Laufe der Zeit kam dann, also wir waren sehr schnell in dem Fall, weil wir auch noch auf zusätzliche Ressourcen zurückgreifen konnten. In dem Fall waren es die Rapid Eye Daten von Rapid Eye selbst.
Das ist ein Satellit.
Das ist ein Satellit, hat sechs Meter Auflösung, im optischen Bereich hat noch ein paar Bänder mehr.
Der ist von den NASA?
Nein, der ist von Rapid Eye. Ach so, das ist ein privater? Genau, das ist eine Firma, die sitzt in Brandenburg und hat eine Konstellation von fünf Satelliten. Und damit können sie sehr schnell auf Ereignisse reagieren, was prädestiniert für so eine Anwendung. Und mit der Breite des Aufnahmestreifens, der lag auch noch optimal, man konnte direkt fast den gesamten Küssenverlauf mit einem Aufnahmestreifen abdecken, kamen wir dann auch sehr schnell an gute Aufnahmen ran.
Das heißt, es war eher Zufall, dass der Rapid Eye in dem Moment gerade über Japan flog?
Nö, die Konstellation erzielt relativ schnell einen brauchbaren Aufnahmestreifen. Der Zufall lag mehr darin, dass für optische Daten braucht man immer noch den Zufall, dass bei der Katastrophe gutes Wetter herrscht.
Das war ja der Fall, ja.
Und das war da der Fall, wie auch beispielsweise bei HIT 2010. Aber für Japan konnten wir dann eben sehr schnell auf sehr gute optische Daten zurückgreifen. Und irgendwann war dann auch klar, dass Deutschland Unterstützung sendet in Form von THW-Mitarbeitern. Und als die dann vor Ort waren, das war, glaube ich, abends um 7 Uhr angerufen, sie brauchen von einem bestimmten Ort, Tomei, brauchen sie eine aktuelle Aufnahme, aktuelle Karten. Und wir haben uns dann mit European Space Imaging zusammengeschlossen, für die wir hier auch am EOC das Bodensegment für die Aufnahmen betreiben. Und haben es dann geschafft, dass nach 16 Stunden das fertige Produkt beim THW war. Das heißt, von der Nutzeanfrage für Neuaufnahmen und Analyse bis zur ausfertigen Auslieferung gab es nur 16 Stunden Zeitdifferenz.
Und was war dann quasi der Inhalt dieses Paketes? Also über welche Daten konnten dann der THW konkret verfügen?
Das ist eine Schadenskarte für dieses Gebiet, was sie sich gewünscht haben. Das war jetzt in dem Fall ein Ort, wo auch ihre Base of Operations war, wo ihr Standort war und von wo sie aus ihre Einsätze koordinieren sollten.
Das heißt, sie konnten mit was für einer Auflösung?
In dem Fall ungefähr ein halber Meter.
Ein halber Meter, also quasi über jeden Quadratmeter konnte man sagen, ob der viel Schaden hat oder nicht.
Genau, also für Schadensanalysen braucht man eigentlich genau diese Datenklasse, ein Meter oder besser. Ansonsten tut man sich relativ schwer.
Weil man zu viele Sachen mit einbezieht, die dann aussehen wie Schaden, aber gar keine sind?
Weil man einfach keine sichere Aussage treffen kann. Also je größer die Bildpixel sind, desto mehr Inhalt ist in einem Bildpixel schon vereint. Und desto verschmierter sehen die Bilder dann auch aus und desto weniger genau sehe ich den Schaden.
Und das war jetzt allein auf den Daten, den der Rapid Eye geliefert hat, basiert?
Das war auf Daten von Worldview und GOI. Das sind zwei andere Missionen, amerikanische Missionen, die über Real-Pin-Space-Imaging vertrieben werden. Für die Rapid Eye Daten haben wir für die großflächige Schadensanalyse entlang der Küste dann gemacht oder hergenommen.
Und als dann der Tsunami aufschlug, gab es dann quasi eine neue Anfrage oder eine erweiterte Anfrage?
Meistens verschmelzt man dann die beiden Anfragen. Also wenn es sich immer noch um ein und dasselbe Ereignis handelt, dann ist es meistens so, dass die Ereignisse sich ein bisschen oder dass die auch kaskadieren können, dass es sich im Laufe der Zeit verändert. Ob das jetzt geografisch ist, dass ich erst die Überflutung am Oberlauf habe und es dann den Fluss hinunterläuft, dann habe ich verschiedene AOIs, man lässt es aber trotzdem mit einer Aktivierung. Oder wie jetzt im Tsunamifall in Japan, dass sich das Ereignis an sich ein bisschen verändert, aber die Aktivierung bleibt dann trotzdem dieselbe. Die Produkte oder die Anfrage an sich ist dann ein bisschen anders, aber man trennt es dann nicht zwingend.
Wie viele Leute haben denn dann daran gearbeitet?
Im ZKI? Über die Zeit vielleicht gleichzeitig 7 oder 8, das hängt aber wirklich davon ab, wie auch die Daten eintrudeln. Für HIT war es ein bisschen anders, das war eine riesige Fläche von vornherein. Und der Wunsch war ein detailliertes Damage Assessment, also auch das Produkt war mit viel Arbeitsaufwand verbunden. Und da hatten wir dann zum Teil 20 bis 25 Leute, die parallel kartiert haben.
Also HIT, wir sprechen von dem großen Erdbeben in HIT, 2010 im Januar 2010. Auch das ist über, also wo kam da die Anfrage dann her? Hat HIT da? HIT hat ja wahrscheinlich dann das über die UN dann aktiviert. Wäre ich das richtig?
Für HIT war es insofern interessant, dass mehrere unterschiedliche Organisationen gleichzeitig aktiviert haben. Jede Charteragentur kann auch für eine andere auslösen oder für eine andere Organisation. In dem Fall waren es sowohl die Kanadier als auch die Deutschen, als auch die Franzosen und dann sprang noch irgendwann auch noch kurzfristig die UN mit auf. Also wir hatten nicht das Problem, dass wir so wenig Anfragen gehabt hätten. Aber das Gute ist ja, dass alle mehr oder weniger die gleiche Information haben wollen. Also ist nicht deshalb dann mehr Arbeit.
Wie lange, vielleicht bleiben wir trotzdem noch mal so ein bisschen bei dem Japan-Desaster, weil man da, glaube ich, eine ganze Menge daran festmachen kann. Wie lange ist man denn dann beschäftigt? Die Katastrophe ist ja eigentlich bis heute noch nicht so richtig beseitigt. Ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Überblick, den man haben muss, so jetzt mittlerweile existiert.
Also für Japan war, wenn man es jetzt wieder an der Charter festmacht, war die Aktivierung relativ lange offen. Klassischerweise sind die Charteraktivierung 10 bis 14 Tage offen. Dann sagt man, normalerweise ist dann die akute Krise erst mal vorbei, dann geht es in eine andere Phase über. Und für Japan war es, glaube ich, letzten Endes fast vier Wochen offen. Wobei sich das natürlich dann auch verschoben hat. Das ZKI war dann nicht in allen Phasen präsent. Wir waren mit die Schnellsten und sind dann aber zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt wieder ausgestiegen, weil sich das dann nicht nur Richtung Tsunami verschoben hatte, von Erdbeben zu Tsunami, sondern dann war es dann eine nukleare Katastrophe. Und da sind wir dann relativ schon in der Mitte, wo es dann die Tsunami-Anfrage war, wieder ausgestiegen, weil wir unsere Arbeit dann schon geleistet hatten. Wir waren dann schon fertig.
Und die nukleare Katastrophe in dem Sinne hat aber keinerlei nennenswerte Anfragen jetzt nach sich gezogen, oder?
Es gab schon Anfragen, aber das ist nichts, was wir mit Erdbeeroberachtung großartig bedienen können. Also das ZKI ist ja was, Herr Service, was ich versteht, dass es nochmal Analysen auf Satellitendaten aufsetzt. Wir sind keine reinen Datenbereitsteller. Dafür gibt es die kommerziellen Wege, dafür gibt es die Charter. Das müssen nicht wir machen. Und wenn ich wissen will, wie ist der Zustand des Kernkraftwerks, dann brauche ich halt nur höchst auflösende Satellitenbilder. Und das war in dem Fall eigentlich ganz gut abgedeckt.
Okay, also hier geht es vor allem um den Gesamtkontext.
Genau.
Wenn man jetzt diese Dinge dann entscheiden muss, ist man dann, weiter bleiben wir bei Japan, also es kam die Anfrage Erdbeben, so war schon klar. Okay, jetzt muss man eben verschiedene Satellitenbetreiber ansprechen. Wie gut sind da die, also wie direkt sind da die Kanäle? Sehr direkt nehme ich mal an.
Ja.
Da ruft man dann an und die haben auch eine entsprechende Notfallnummer.
Ja, also bei der Charter, die ist zum Beispiel genau darauf ausgerichtet. Innerhalb von drei Stunden nach der Anfrage des Nutzers, dann muss man natürlich erstmal überprüfen, ist die Anfrage korrekt, was muss man dafür ordern. Spätestens nach drei Stunden hat jede Raumfahrtagentur, die dafür notwendig ist, sozusagen das Autofomular für das Tasking der Satelliten vorliegen. Und dann hat man noch, ich sag mal, das dauert noch mal ein, zwei Stunden, dann sind die Satelliten normalerweise programmiert. Und dann hängt es wieder von der Mission ab und den Orbit-Parametern, wann fliegt der spezielle Satellit da wieder drüber und kann aufnehmen. Das kann manchmal sehr schnell gehen, das kann manchmal aber auch vielleicht dann doch noch einen Tag oder vielleicht noch zwei dauern.
Aber jetzt Terraza X und Tandem X sind auch zum Einsatz gekommen in Japan? Und was heißt das dann konkret? Also was wird da veranlasst? Also man sagt denen, das nächste Mal, wenn ihr über Japan fliegt, übertragt doch bitte alles, was ihr habt.
Der Punkt ist, grundsätzlich nehmen die diese Sensoren ja nicht permanent auf, sondern man muss denen ja dann sagen, wann und wo. Und das wann hängt vom Orbit ab und das wo hängt von dem AOI ab, was wir vom Nutzer bekommen. Das heißt, wir brauchen auf der einen Seite AOI, AOI heißt Area of Interest. Das heißt, er spezifiziert, wo will er Information haben oder für welches Gebiet und mit dem geht man dann in die Satellitenprogrammierung dann rein. Und für uns, für Japan war es dann so, dass wir ja dann schon Chartermitglied waren. Wir wussten dann ganz schnell auch vom Epizentrum des Erdbeams her, wo sind die Hauptbetroffenen oder womöglich Hauptbetroffenen Küstenabschnitte und haben darauf dann den Satelliten ausgeführt und ausgerichtet. Und das ZKI hat eben auch eine Funktion innerhalb der Charter, das heißt, wir programmieren dann für Charteranfragen, wo TerraSatX gebraucht werden kann, dann diese Systeme und da haben wir auf unserem PC-Terminal einfach eine Software, womit wir uns dann einloggen können und den Satelliten dann programmieren können.
Dazu muss man sagen, wir befinden uns ja hier in Oberpfaffenhofen auf dem Gelände, wo noch sehr viele andere Institute untergebracht sind, unter anderem eben auch das GSOC, das German Space Operations Center, und eine Aufgabe des GSOC ist halt die Steuerung des TerraSatX-Projektes und TandemX-Projektes.
Genau, dort findet die Missionskontrolle statt.
Das ist also hier quasi in Spuckweite. Sprich, man kann hier einfach direkt auf die Systeme zugreifen. Es gibt hier quasi einen direkten Zugang, oder lässt man das GSOC machen?
Nein, also das ist soweit automatisiert, dass das GSOC da nicht direkt angesprochen werden muss, sondern es ist einfach schon vorgegeben über zum Beispiel Order-Prioritäten. Man kriegt einen Zugang, um ordern zu können, und der wird mit gewissen Rechten versehen, sodass alles andere danach beim Ordern automatisch passieren kann. Und diese Krisenanwendungen gehen halt mit einer sehr hohen Priorität rein, das heißt, die können kaum überstimmt werden oder rausgeworfen werden können, wenn sie mal im System sind. Und das heißt, wir geben einfach nur ein, und dann kriegen wir irgendwann das prozessierte Bild raus. Alles andere ist automatisiert. Es würde, glaube ich, für ziemlich viel Chaos sorgen, wenn man dann erst noch zur Missionskontrolle rennen müsste oder zum Gesag rüber und dann zu sagen, ja, dreht da mal.
Wie lange braucht Terraza, um einmal komplett um die Erde herum zu sein? Da muss man nachdenken.
Gute Frage, ich glaube. Wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht. 90 oder 100 Minuten.
Ja, also relativ schnell.
Das heißt... Aber die Erde dreht sich ja dann drunter weg. Und bis er dann beispielsweise, wenn er immer auf dem Orbit bleibt, immer in die gleiche Richtung schaut. Es gibt ja verschiedene Streifen. Er schaut eigentlich nach rechts. Und man kann den Einfallswinkel dann noch verändern. Das heißt, man kann noch ein bisschen bestimmen, wo er dann tatsächlich hinschaut. Wenn man aber alles konstant lässt und man lässt ihn einfach nur um die Erde fliegen und den gleichen Streifen aufnehmen, dann würde er, glaube ich, nach elf Tagen über die identische Stelle wieder mit den gleichen Aufnahmeparametern fliegen. Alles andere funktioniert dann über die Verstellung von den... Man kann den Streifen breiter wählen. Es gibt drei verschiedene Aufnahmemodi. Die dann unterschiedliche Auflösungen haben und in Abhängigkeit von Auflösungen natürlich in unterschiedlich großen Aufnahmestreifen. Und man kann die Einfallswinkel noch verändern.
Aber das müsste man dann sozusagen auch alles machen, um auf diese niedrigen Zeiten zu kommen.
Auf die niedrigen Zeiten, das hängt dann auch wieder davon ab, wo das Ereignis auf der Welt passiert. Weil die Streifen, diese Orbits von der Bahnkonstellation natürlich am Pol deutlich näher zusammenliegen bzw. sich sogar überschneiden und am Äquator weiter auseinanderliegen. Das heißt, ich habe eine viel höhere Wiederholrate oder Wiederholmöglichkeit von Aufnahmen, je höher das in den Breiten liegt.
Wobei Japan da sozusagen in der Mitte liegt.
Ja, also Japan war okay von der geografischen Lage her.
Das heißt, nachdem jetzt die erste Anfrage reinkam, hat man dann auch sofort TerraSAR angeworfen. Also das war sozusagen gleich so, da brauchen wir jetzt mal ein Bild. Und wie lange hat er dann gebraucht?
Wann die erste Aufnahme reinkam, kann ich gar nicht genau sagen. Interessant war, dass wir dort eine sehr schöne Auf- oder eine sehr schöne Analyse machen konnten, was die Überflutungsflächen des Tsunamis angehen. Weil wir da nicht nur die Wasserflächen detektieren konnten, sondern aufgrund der Analyse auch die Bereiche, wo der Tsunami die Schuttmassen aufgeschoben hatte, die ja vorne an der Welle sich dann ablagern. Wenn der Tsunami sich dann zurückzieht, bleibt das alles liegen. Da das aber natürlich auch die Rückstreuung deutlich verändert zum Vorher-Bild, konnte man das auch sehr schön in den Daten erkennen. Und das hat dann so eine Indikation gegeben, wie weit der Tsunami bis ins Land reingelaufen ist. Ah, verstehe.
Also an der Stelle ist die Höheninformation dann doch interessant. Aber man hat es jetzt nicht auf einen Zentimeter ausgerechnet, sondern nur grob erkannt hier hat sich signifikant was in der Höhe getan.
In dem Fall haben wir nicht mal die Höheninformation genommen, sondern einfach nur die Rückstreuung. Also ob es rauer geworden ist an der Stelle oder ob es glatter geworden ist.
Das kann man so direkt rauslesen aus den Daten.
Genau, also beim Radarbild grob gesprochen ist, wenn je rauer die Oberfläche zumindest im gewissen Bandbereich ist, desto stärker wird das Signal zum Sensor zurück gestreut. Und damit erscheint es dann im Bild, weil wir haben ein Grau-Werte-Bild, also nur von weiß bis schwarz, wird es dann heller. Und wenn es flach ist und vom Sensor weggespiegelt wird, dann zeigt es sich im Bild eher dunkel.
D.h., man konnte den Tsunami-Fußabdruck quasi als weiße Linie erkennen?
Ja, manchmal nicht so einfach, aber prinzipiell ja.
Was natürlich dann auch nicht... Das ist dann sozusagen auch Teil der Daten, die man zurückliefert. Da sieht man sofort, ist das normal bei solchen Überflutungen, dass man sowas hat, oder war das jetzt nur, weil die Dimension des Tsunamis in Japan so extrem war? Konnte man schon davon ausgehen, dass man das so ablesen können wird, oder war das dann eher eine Überraschung?
In der Qualität war das eigentlich schon eine Überraschung. Das hängt natürlich auch wieder mit den Bedingungen vor Ort zusammen, und wie die Tsunamiwelle reingelaufen ist, und wie hoch sie war. Wenn sie beispielsweise unter Bäumen nur langläuft und vielleicht gar nicht so stark war, dann sehe ich auch nachher nicht viel in der Veränderung der Rücksteuerung. Und auch für die Küstenart war das eigentlich schon ganz gut. Und den Bebauungstyp dort hat uns das Ergebnis eigentlich sehr positiv überrascht und gezeigt, dass diese Art der Analyse auch womöglich für zukünftige Tsunami-Ereignisse eine ganz gute Alternative darstellt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist man eigentlich auch ein bisschen negativ überrascht. Ich meine, das ist ja dann auch so eine technokratische Art und Weise, an so einer Katastrophe teilzunehmen. Man sitzt da, man hat Zahlen, man hat Daten, man freut sich darüber, wenn man die Katastrophe gemessen hat, ist ja klar. Auf der anderen Seite realisiert man eigentlich, was da passiert oder blendet man das total aus? Also ist man da irgendwie mit reingeschaltet oder ist man so sehr auf den eigentlichen Aufgabe konzentriert, dass man das vollständig ausblendet?
Also ganz ausschalten kann man es definitiv nicht. Und es ist natürlich auch ein Teil der Motivation. Man nimmt dieses Ereignis wahr, man weiß, welche Tragweite das hat und man versucht zu helfen. Das ist auch sehr wichtig als Hintergrund für die Arbeit dort. Ansonsten kann es schon mal sein, dass die Motivation auch einbrechen kann, wenn man dann morgens um vier nach zwölf Stunden Dauerarbeit immer noch dran sitzt, um irgendein Kartenprodukt fertigzustellen. Insgesamt ist es aber so, dass wir, wenn wir eine Aktivierung haben und eine Karte erstellen müssen und Daten prozessieren müssen, natürlich unter Hochdruck arbeiten und da hat man relativ wenig Zeit, sich noch um andere Dinge im Kopf zu machen, sondern man ist schon sehr fokussiert auf die Arbeit und auf seine eigene Rolle.
Diese Systeme, die jetzt da zum Einsatz kommen, also ich habe kurz vorher noch einen kleinen Rundgang gemacht, da gibt es also in dem Bereich für das Datenfernerkundungsdatenzentrum, hast du richtig gesagt? Ja, gibt es halt einen speziellen Raum, wo quasi alle zusammenarbeiten in dem Moment dann auch. Das heißt, die acht Leute, die da gleichzeitig dran gearbeitet haben, sitzen auch wirklich in einem Raum. Das ist jetzt nicht verteilt über ein ganzes Gebäude, sondern man hat so richtig auch so ein Krisenzentrum.
Genau.
Man sich das so mit Bildschirmen an der Wand, etc.
Seit einem Jahr haben wir das. Es ist so eine Art Kontrollraum und auch so eine Art Krisenraum, Lagezentrum. Da gibt es verschiedene Namen, mit denen man das belegen kann. Es ist so, dass wir relativ wenig Zeit haben. Die Kommunikation stellt einen wichtigen Faktor dar. Von daher ist es sehr wichtig, dass die Leute eng miteinander zusammenarbeiten und schnell Informationen austauschen können. Daher macht so ein Raum mehr als nur Sinn. Wir haben dort sechs Rechnerplätze, die für die meisten Aktivierungen auch ausreichen. Im Notfall können wir das dann auch noch erweitern. Wir können auf Büroräume zugreifen oder die Referenzplattform. Ein vergleichbarer Raum, der nur zehn Meter über den Gang liegt. Wir können dort dann eben in konzentrierter Form arbeiten. Prinzipiell sind es sechs Server, die alle nötige Software dann drauf haben. Jeder Rechner ist für die einzelne Rolle speziell eingerichtet, weil nicht jeder alle Software braucht oder jegliche Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten. Und dann wird dort eben kartiert, Daten prozessiert, Daten empfangen, Daten vorbereitet, Geoinformation eingesammelt, schon die Kartenprodukte vorbereitet und natürlich auch mit dem Nutzer kommuniziert. Verändert sich die Lage, braucht er was neues? Vielleicht hat er selbst Information aus dem Feld. Das ist für uns nämlich auch immer ganz wichtig, dass wir unsere Produkte auch soweit es möglich ist, vor Herausgabe schon mit Informationen aus dem Internet vom Nutzer, einfach Feldinformationen in einer gewissen Form schon validieren können, dass wir sicher sein können, dass das, was wir rausgeben, auch der Wahrheit entspricht. Natürlich ist es so, je schneller man ist, desto ungenauer sind natürlich die Informationen. Wenn ich mehr Zeit habe, kann ich natürlich viel mehr Arbeit reinstecken und viel genauere Endprodukte erzeugen.
Bei solchen Datenmuster, die ja auch eine gewisse Verlässlichkeit in sich bergen müssen, muss man ja dann auch sicherstellen, dass die auch wirklich akkurat sind. Und abgesehen davon, dass man überhaupt erst mal gute Quellen braucht und die natürlich korrekt auswerten muss, stelle ich mir jetzt gerade bei dieser Korrelation mit anderen Daten vor, dass ein Kernproblem einfach so in den Formaten auch liegt. Gibt es überhaupt ausreichend Standards und Definitionen von Geoinformationen, um jetzt solche krisenbezogenen Daten auch korrekt abzubilden, sodass man sich sicher sein kann, dass es auch auf der anderen Seite Software gibt, die damit richtig umgehen kann? Ist das ausreichend standardisiert?
Ja, also das sind natürlich verschiedene Aspekte. Der eine ist, habe ich ein möglichst genau zusammenpassendes Vorher-Nachher-Paar. Das ist inzwischen bei den meisten Sensoren gegeben. Es hängt immer davon ab, wie lange ist eine Mission schon im Orbit. Haben sie genug Zeit gehabt, ein gewisses Archiv aufzubauen, damit ich dann, wenn eine Katastrophe passiert, eine Neuaufnahme machen kann und aber eine Szene habe, die ich dazu vergleichen kann. Im Notfall müssen wir aber fähig sein, das mit Bildern ähnlicher Sensoren zu vergleichen. Wenn ich jetzt das Beispiel RapidEye hernehme, dann muss ich eine RapidEye-Nachher-Aufnahme auch mit einer Spot, das ist ein französischer Satellit, Vorher-Aufnahme vergleichen können. Oder, wenn es ganz dumm läuft, vielleicht sogar eine Aufnahme aus einem von einem optischen Sensor mit einem Vorher-Bild, also ein Radar-Bild. Das ist natürlich eine sehr, sehr knifflige Sache, aber theoretisch müsste man auch dafür oder dazu in der Lage sein. Und für manche Ereignisse reicht uns tatsächlich manchmal auch einfach nur ein Nachher-Bild.
Gibt es denn da so ein standardisiertes Format, in dem alle Satelliten ihre Daten ausspucken, oder ist das so, dass wirklich die Daten von jedem Satelliten irgendwie ganz anders sind und man muss alles erstmal konvertieren und aufeinander anpassen?
Nee, also jede Mission oder jeder Datenprovider hat natürlich schon gewisse vordefinierte Datenformate. Und die Software, die Standardsoftware, die ist auch problemlos in der Lage, diese zu prozessieren oder zu übereinanderzulegen, Imagefitting zu machen oder... Also das ist wirklich überhaupt kein Problem. Das Knifflige ist dann eigentlich eher das Extrahieren der Kriseninformation.
Und das Darstellen auch der... Ja, das muss man ja dann auch wieder in diese Daten hineinweben. Hier ist was passiert oder hier ist ein Flüchtlingsgebiet oder hier sieht es nach dieser Art Schaden aus. Hier sieht es nach dieser Art Schaden aus. Das ist ja auch eine Taxonomieproblematik. Man muss da Kategorien haben, Klassifizierungen haben.
Wir versuchen in unserem Service möglichst flexibel zu sein. Auch was die Darstellung angeht, versuchen wir uns dem anzupassen, was der Nutzer tatsächlich haben will. Wir können die Kriseninformation, die aus den Satellitendaten abgeleitet ist, entweder auf eine standardisierte topografische Karte legen, auf Landnutzungsklassen. Man kennt es vielleicht noch aus der Schule, thematische Karten, die dann nicht mehr Gebirge oder Höhenlinien zeigen, sondern nur noch verschiedene bunte Flächen, die aussagen, welche Nutzung da tatsächlich stattfindet. So kann ich dann Agrarflächen, Stadtflächen, Wasserflächen voneinander abkriegen. Das ist eine sehr einfache Darstellungsart. Wir können es aber genauso auf die klassische deutsche topografische Karte legen, wenn der deutsche Nutzer sagt, er ist gewohnt damit umzugehen, dann machen wir das. Wir können es aber, und das ist die klassische Form des ZKI-Produkts, als einfach auf einen, tatsächlich auf einen Satellitenhintergrund zu legen. Und dann muss man natürlich mit den Farben und mit den Symbolen spielen, wenn das nicht immer farblich passt.
Aber die Einsatzkräfte vor Ort, also ich denke jetzt so THW, wenn die jetzt da in dieser Gegend, in Tomei, die haben ja jetzt konkret die Anfrage gestellt, wir hätten jetzt hier ganz gerne mal Schadenausmaßkarten, die sie ja dann auch bekommen haben, 16 Stunden waren es. So, in welcher Form haben die das dann bekommen? Haben die das dann gleich in einer Form bekommen, dass sie das auf ihre GPS-Geräte mit einspielen können? Oder sind das erst mal nur Daten, die dann einer Zentrale vorliegen und dann müssen die selber sehen, wie sie damit umgehen? Können die das gleich auch in the field zum Einsatz bringen?
Ja, also in dem Fall ist es so gewesen, dass das DIY sich einfach eine JPEG-Karte gewünscht hat und die kann man sich dann einfach ausdrucken. Also da sind dann alle Informationen drin. Das ist eine klassische Karte mit Kartenrandinformation und alle Kriseninformationen auf einen Satellitenhintergrund gelegt. Es hat das klassische Look and Feel von einer Karte. Und das kann man sich sehr simpel dann einfach ausdrucken in unterschiedlichen Formaten und sich in seine Koordinationszentrale hängen und daran dann den Einsatz planen. Wir können aber auch jede einzelne Informationsebene, die wir abgeleitet haben, seien es die unterschiedlich zerstörten Häuser oder das Straßennetz. Alles, was wir abgeleitet haben, können wir als einzelne digitale Informationsebene genauso bereitstellen und die der Nutzer, THW, World Food Programme, wer auch immer, können sich das dann einfach in ihr Gist-Tool vor Ort einspielen und mit den für sie schon vorliegenden Gistinformationen verschneiden. Also dahin geht auch inzwischen der Trend. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es das gesamte Spektrum von womöglich auch laminierter, ausgedruckter Karte, die dann mit in Flieger genommen wird, bis hin zu Geodatabases, wo dann die einzelnen Informationen schon als digitale Informationen gestapelt ist, was man als Paket dann rübergeben kann. Was natürlich mit den neuen Technologien viel einfacher ist, dann auch zu kombinieren, wieder zu verwerten, individuelle Produkte vor Ort dann noch mal daraus zu bauen.
Geoinformationssystem ist ein sehr genereller Begriff eigentlich für eine sehr umfassende Forschung und sehr umfassendes Forschungsfeld, Produkt- und Firmenfeld, was es gibt, wo zahlreiche Produkte gemacht werden. Wie kompatibel ist da alles zueinander? Wenn nicht überall, wo es draufsteht, heißt das, dass es mit allem anderen, wo es draufsteht, problemlos zusammenarbeitet, oder?
Ja, also wenn man die Standard-Software hernimmt, dann ist es auch kein Problem heute mehr. Wenn man dann den Service, das ZKI als Gesamtes sieht, gibt es natürlich Bereiche, die über die Standard-Software nicht abgedeckt sind und da bauen wir uns dann auch was selber, dass dann bestimmte Prozesse automatisiert werden, standardisiert werden, dass bestimmte Teilschritte dann einfach nur noch per Knopfdruck funktionieren, anstatt dass man dann selber noch mal was über andere Software anpflanschen muss. Das Ziel ist ZKI, dass wir solche Dinge eben möglichst standardisieren, dass wir auch da kein Risiko mehr in der Aktivierung eingehen, dass da Fehler passieren können.
Ist es denn schon mal vorgekommen oder ist es zumindest vorstellbar für die Zukunft, dass eine Anfrage jetzt gar nicht mal nur darin endet, dass man jetzt die Daten nur einem Nutzer, nämlich derjenige, der sie angefragt hat, zur Verfügung stellt, sondern dass die dann gleich öffentlich gemacht werden?
Der Ansatz des ZKI ist, dass jegliche Analyse, jegliches Produkt, was wir erstellen, auch über unsere Webseite verfügbar ist. Also wenn wir was erzeugen, dann wird es auch auf der ZKI-Webseite gezeigt.
Das heißt, die Daten sind quasi dort zum Download für jedermann zu haben?
Ja, also Daten muss man wieder unterscheiden. Die Satellitendaten nicht. Die unterliegen bestimmten Lizenzbedingungen, die werden nur ans ZKI in den meisten Fällen ausgeliefert. Wir arbeiten mit denen und generieren Analyseprodukte. Und diese, meistens in Kartenform oder als Webmapping-Service, die werden dann wieder bereitgestellt. Und die sind dann auch frei verfügbar.
In welchen Formaten liegt dann das vor? Also inwiefern ist das jetzt so für jedermann verwendbar? Oder muss man dann auch diese aufwendigen Systeme haben, um das überhaupt irgendwie weiterverwenden zu können?
Nö, also die Formate, die wir im Moment bereitstellen, ist einfach eine JPEG-Karte. In JPEG kann sich normalerweise jeder öffnen mit seinem handelsüblichen PC und der Software, die drauf ist, ausdrucken, genauso. Wir stellen meistens noch die Produkte auch als KML oder KMZ-File bereit. Das heißt, man kann sich die Kartenprodukte auch direkt bei Google Earth reinladen. Das ist auch ein frei verfügbares Tool, was auch ganz nett ist. Und dann kann man sich sehr schnell eben auch in das Gebiet reinzoomen und wieder rauszoomen und die ZKI-Karte rein- und rausklicken. Und je nach Aktivierung und wenn es gewünscht ist, sind auch zum Teil die Vektordaten dann verfügbar. Aber die Vektordaten sind natürlich, auch wenn da der Trend hingeht, immer noch so eine bisschen kniffelige Sache, weil die sehr leicht auch manipuliert werden können. Wir versehen sie schon mit sehr ausführlichen Metadaten, die dann Auskunft darüber geben, unter welchen Bedingungen die Daten abgeleitet wurden, wie sollen sie verwendet werden, in welchem Maßstabsbereich zum Beispiel, wie ist das ZKI oder das DLR zu referenzieren. Aber man ist nicht gezwungen, da reinzuschauen. Das heißt, man kann sich einfach die Vektorisierte Umrisslinie von der Flu zum Beispiel hernehmen und die anderweitig wieder verwenden oder die Umrisslinie einfach manipulieren und verschieben.
Ist das jetzt ein theoretisches Szenario oder gibt es da jetzt eine Kanzlation, wo das auch schon mal schief gelaufen ist?
Ich sage mal schief gelaufen, nicht zwingend. Wir haben es schon mal gesehen, dass es auf einer anderen Plattform dargestellt wurde. Es war nicht mehr unsere Original-Ebene. Sie hatte noch eine gewisse Verwandtschaft, aber es wurde halt das ZKI oder das DLR als Quelle genannt und dann sind wir da nicht mehr ganz so glücklich drüber.
Das kann ich verstehen. Wobei man das Problem natürlich theoretisch auch mit allen anderen Daten hätte, nur dass es bei Vector etwas einfacher ist, weil es sich halt um diese Rohmaterialien handelt. Ich will ja nicht zu sehr darauf rumreiten, aber gerade im Kontext Haiti gab es ja auch in Japan später auch so von einer breiten Internet-Nutzerschaft getriebene Hilfsmaßnahme. Vor allem wurde OpenStreetMap innerhalb kürzester Zeit Haiti quasi neu kategografiert. Bis dahin war das Projekt noch sehr gering ausgeprägt in dem Land. Und dann gibt es da so schöne Filmchen, die man sich anschauen kann, in wie wenigen Tagen fast jedes Gässchen in Haiti in OpenStreetMap erfasst wurde. Ist das irgendetwas, was hier auch berücksichtigt wird? Ist diese Verallgemeinschaftung von Geoprojekten, speziell OpenStreetMap, vielleicht nicht nur OpenStreetMap, spielt das hier eine Rolle?
Werden Daten auch dafür gemacht? Wir schauen natürlich, welche globalen Entwicklungen sich auftun. Und dieses Thema Crowdsourcing, also dass Informationen durch die Allgemeinheit bereitgestellt werden oder erfasst werden, ist natürlich zunehmend interessant. Man muss das aber auch wieder sehr differenziert sehen. Als das Erdbeben in Haiti war, war die Datenlage auch in USM, also OpenStreetMap, schlecht, nicht brauchbar. Das erste, was wir dann eben gemacht haben, weil Logistik im Vordergrund steht, eine erste Aufgabe vom ZKI war ein ausführliches Straßennetzkartieren. Das hatten wir definitiv vor USM dann. Aber das lag auch vorher nicht vor, es gab nicht in der Genauigkeit, wie wir es gebraucht hätten. Und so ist es in vielen Bereichen. Ich sag mal, es gibt auf der Welt Gebiete, die sind sehr gut durch USM abgedeckt. Es gibt aber auch sehr große Gebiete, wo die Datenlage noch relativ schlecht ist. Und das hängt dann auch an der Größe des Ereignisses, ob dann die Community, USM-Community, drauf aufspringt oder nicht. Also für kleinere Ereignisse, wofür das ZKI vielleicht dann trotzdem kartiert, kann es sein, dass trotzdem nichts passiert und die Datenlage vorher trotzdem schlecht ist. Und dann bleibt uns gar nichts anderes übrig, als selbst das Straßennetz beispielsweise aufzunehmen oder die Flussläufe zu digitalisieren. Aber für HIT war es dann schon beeindruckend, wie dann die Entwicklung danach stattgefunden hat. HIT ist in vielerlei Hinsicht ein interessanter Punkt gewesen. Und zwar war das Ereignis so groß und hat natürlich dann mal wieder ein Land getroffen, was nicht die eigenen Kapazitäten hat, um mit der Katastrophe zurechtzukommen. Sehr armes Land, eines der ärmsten überhaupt. Und bei den Kartierungen sind so viele unterschiedliche Organisationen dann auch aktiv geworden, unterschiedliche Mechanismen, dass man innerhalb von zwei Wochen ungefähr 350 Kartenprodukte hatte, die mehr oder weniger ähnliche Dinge ausgesagt haben. Wenn man sich jetzt in die Rolle des Nutzers versetzt, dann fühlt man sich womöglich ein bisschen überfordert mit dieser schieren Masse an Kartenprodukten, die für sich zum Beispiel noch keinen einheitlichen Qualitätslevel haben. Also man kann an der Karte selbst noch nicht erkennen, außer man hat einen gigantischen Überblick über die Erfahrung der Krisenkartierer, die Einbindung in den globalen Kontext, in die Algorithmen, die vielleicht dafür verwendet wurden. Kann man relativ schwer einschätzen, wie gut oder wie schlecht die Qualität von diesen Kartenprodukten ist. Und dann so eine Auswahl zu haben, ist dann natürlich relativ schwierig.
Aber man könnte im Nachgang wiederum die Karten natürlich auch gut miteinander vergleichen, auch wenn das natürlich ein aufwendiger Vorgang ist.
Genau.
Also wenn jetzt in 99 Prozent aller Karten bestimmte Dinge identisch sind, dann kann man später davon ausgehen, dass hier kein Fehler vorliegt.
Ja, also für HIT hat man sich dann sogar noch andere Dinge zu Nutze gemacht. Es hat dann eine sehr ausführliche Mission dorthin gegeben danach und hat ganz Porto Bronze noch mal kartiert, von der Straße aus, welche Gebäude eingestürzt sind, welche nicht, sodass man eine sehr gute Ground Truth-Datenlage hatte, um dann die Produkte im Nachhinein zu validieren.
Sind die auch schon validiert worden? Weiß man, welche Fehlerquote man so hatte?
Fehlerquote ist immer relativ. Also ich kann, ich sag mal, 70% Genauigkeit kann je nachdem, wann ich das Produkt erzeugt habe, sehr gut oder sehr schlecht sein. Okay. Wenn ich dafür...
Dafür war es halt sofort da und seitdem hat sich ja dann auch vor Ort wieder was verändert. Aber trotzdem, Validierung heißt ja im Prinzip, dass man die ursprüngliche Annahme durch den Blick von oben noch mal einer Überprüfung unterzieht.
Ja, also die genauen Zahlen habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber sowohl die ZKI-Karten als auch die von unseren Kollegen aus dem Safer-Projekt, die waren sehr gut. Also da kommt zu schnell auch erstmal nichts ran.
Aber welche Zukunft hätte denn so dieser Crowdsourcing-Aspekt? Ich meine, dass das ein Problem ist, dass man nicht weiß, wer da agiert und quasi die Verlässlichkeit der Quelle nicht so ohne weiteres bestimmt werden kann. Aber das kann ja dann hier unter Umständen die Masse dann auch wieder wett machen.
Ja, also die Entwicklung ist dann noch ziemlich am Anfang. Es gibt auch europäische Forschungsprojekte, die sich darum kümmern. Eins davon ist beispielsweise Geopictures. Das ist DLR nicht direkt involviert, aber über ein anderes Projekt haben wir gerade Kontakt dazu aufgenommen, um eben zu gucken, wie können wir unsere Dienstleistungen mit eben Crowdsourcing-Informationen vernetzen und damit verbessern. Die sind aber noch relativ am Anfang. Die Idee hinter diesem Projekt ist, eine einfache App zu haben, die auf allen verschiedenen Mobiltelefonen und Betriebssystemen funktioniert. Eine Kamera hat fast jedes inzwischen. GPS ist auch immer an Bord. Das heißt, die Verbindung von ich mache ein Foto mit den Koordinaten und dieses Foto kann dann auf eine Datenbank gespielt werden. Und auf diese Datenbank könnten dann zum Beispiel die Krisenkartiere wieder zugreifen. Und mit dieser Verortung, dieser Bildinformation kann ich zum Beispiel schon mal sehen, wo ist welche Überflutung, ist in diesem Straßenzug, wie hoch ist da die Quote der eingestürzten Häuser. So kann ich meine Kartierung tatsächlich schon in Echtzeit verbessern, das ist aber noch sehr am Anfang. Es ist vielversprechend, aber die Ergebnisse zeigen nicht, dass wir das jetzt innerhalb der nächsten sechs Monate operationell anwenden könnten oder so.
Wir sind so vorhin noch so ein bisschen abgekommen, als wir diese Rollen des Teams besprochen haben. Da wollte ich noch mal kurz darauf zurückgehen und vielleicht zu verstehen, wie dieser Fluss ist. Das hat ja sicherlich dann auch ein bisschen was über diese Endergebnisse aus. Wir hatten ja diesen Erstkontakt, klar, nicht wahr? Also die Anfrage reicht ein und dann gab es jetzt den Activation-Manager. Also das ist dann derjenige, der dann quasi sagt, wer jetzt sich um was kümmern soll. Oder wer wird da aktiviert?
Der Erstkontakt bei uns im ZKI nimmt die Anfragen auf, selektiert die schon vor, kann die eventuell schon zum Teil beantworten oder zumindest kanalisieren. Manchmal ist es ja auch so, dass das ZKI vielleicht gar nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner ist. Wenn dann die Anfrage tatsächlich beim ZKI landet und klar ist, dass wir Kartenprodukte erstellen sollen, dann übernimmt in dem Moment der Activation-Manager und der trägt grob gesagt die Verantwortung, dass am Ende der Nutzer das Produkt bekommt, was er am Anfang angefragt hat. Und zur Erfüllung dieser Aufgaben gibt es natürlich dann noch andere Rollen. Der Data-Manager kümmert sich in erster Linie natürlich um die Charter-Aufgaben, was so Datenprogrammierung angeht und Datenprozessierung. Der ist gar nicht zwingend immer notwendig. Wenn allerdings die Aktivierung größer ist, kann man natürlich auf den dann sehr schön noch zurückgreifen. Ansonsten gibt es den Bildverarbeiter, der bekommt die Satellitenbilder, prozessiert die, zieht die zurecht, macht eine Bildverbesserung, macht eine Autorektifizierung, sodass keine Verzerrungen mehr drin sind. Also solche Schritte und macht auch die Bildanalyse, das heißt die Anwendung bestimmter Methoden, Modelle, Algorithmen auf die Satellitendaten, um die Kriseninformation zu erhalten. Und der GIS-Spezialist auf der anderen Seite, der sammelt während der gleichen Zeit schon andere Geoinformationen, die man zur Verfügung hat, sei es die Landcover-Information oder die Straßennetze. USM ist eine Quelle, wo man sich durchaus auch bedienen kann. Aber es gibt noch andere Datensätze, andere Informationsebenen.
Wie können also die Metadaten mit ins Spiel sein?
Ja, die Metadaten, das ist quasi, das hängt an jedem Informationsdatensatz noch dran. Die Metadaten, die beschreiben den Informationsdatensatz nach bestimmten Kriterien. Die Informationsebenen, man kann sich das so vorstellen, vielleicht wie ein Hamburger. Man hat eine Kriseninformationsebene, das ist vielleicht das oberste Brötchen, aber drunter liegen noch ganz viele unterschiedliche andere Informationen. Und am Ende klappt man alles zusammen und hat dann sein finales Produkt. Diese verschiedenen Informationsebenen, die werden dann in der gleichen Zeit eben auch rausgesucht. Und der Activation Manager muss sich eben um die gesamte Außenkommunikation dann auch während der Aktivierung kümmern. Das heißt, mit dem Nutzer in Kontakt bleiben, mit den unterschiedlichen Mechanismen, mit den verschiedenen Projekten, die vielleicht involviert sind.
Ich frage mich, kommt man da immer mit der Standardsoftware, die einem zur Verfügung steht, aus? Oder ist es nicht so, dass jede Krise wieder andere Fragen aufwirft und andere Antworten versucht werden zu generieren, wo die Werkzeuge nicht richtig schon zurecht liegen, sodass man auch noch einen zusätzlichen Softwarebedarf hat? Wird dann auch noch selber Software erstellt? Oder geht es soweit nicht?
Doch, es geht schon soweit. Also in manchen Bereichen ist es so, in manchen Bereichen nicht. Wenn ich nur die Bilddaten prozessieren muss, ich sage mal die Standardschritte, brauche ich keine Spezialsoftware. Das funktioniert auch so. Wenn ich allerdings die Kriseninformation herausziehen will, dann muss ich unter Umständen eigene Algorithmen entwickeln. Und das macht ja auch den Vorteil des ZKI am DLR aus, dass wir genau die Nähe zur Forschung haben. Das heißt, wenn wir erkennen, es gibt ein Defizit in irgendeiner Analyse-Methode, dann können wir mit dieser Erfahrung direkt wieder in die Forschung gehen, können daran weiterbauen und dann die neuen Methoden direkt im operativen Bereich wieder testen und schauen, ob sie besser sind oder schlechter sind. Und das ist ein Kreislauf, der zu einer ständigen Verbesserung der Analyseergebnisse führt.
Aber das ist dann eher so Post-Crisis. Also während es eigentlich ein Kerneinsatz ist, kümmert man sich um solche Sachen nicht.
Nee, da hat man keinen Tiefkeitssatz.
Da könnte der Skripthacker vom Dienst auch noch abgerufen werden und sagt, versuchst du noch mal, diese Metainformation auch noch mit hineinzuspielen.
Natürlich sind die Disasterarten, die Katastrophenarten, unterschiedlich gut abgedeckt. Es gibt Themen, die sind von ihrer Komplexität her relativ einfach und auch einfach zu extrahieren, die Informationen dazu. Im Bereich Flut haben wir da eine sehr starke Kompetenz in den letzten Jahren aufgebaut. Das ist heute straight forward. Da muss man nicht mehr so viel machen. Da gibt es vielleicht noch zwei, drei einzelne Themenbereiche, die das Produkt dann noch am Ende perfektionieren werden. Es gibt aber andere Thematiken, die deutlich komplexer sind. Das ist beispielsweise die Erdbeben-Schadenserfassung, die jetzt nicht einfach nur so gemacht werden können, in eine Standard-Software reinwerfen, egal welche Daten ich habe, und ich kriege eine Schadensanalyse raus. Also für Erdbeben greifen wir heute noch in erster Linie auf die visuelle Interpretation durch Menschen einfach zurück. Das heißt aber, wir haben einen sehr hohen personellen Aufwand für Erdbeben-Schadensanalysen. Und es ist eine ganz andere Art der Analyse. Man muss ganz anders arbeiten können. Wenn ich Flut habe, habe ich einen Algorithmus, Daten rein, Algorithmus rüberlaufen lassen, Flutmaske hinten raus. Bei Erdbeben, wenn ich von der Interpretation einzelner Menschen abhängig bin, muss ich sicherstellen, dass das Niveau halbwegs das gleiche ist, dass ich ein reproduzierbares Ergebnis habe, dass alle ungefähr die gleichen Schäden erkennen. Ich muss ja dann die Fläche aufteilen. Das heißt, wir unterteilen klassischerweise das Gebiet in Quadranten oder in Straßenblöcke und teilen die bestimmten Gruppen zu. Und diese Gruppen machen dann die Schadensanalyse für diese Bereiche und am Ende führen wir dann alles wieder zusammen und ich muss natürlich in dem gesamten Analyseablauf sicherstellen, dass alle auf die gleichen Schäden gehen, auf die gleichen Schadensklassen und das gleiche Verständnis haben, was ein Schaden ist.
Und vergleichbare Daten hat auch überhaupt, die zusammenpassen.
Das heißt, ich habe speziell in diesem Bereich einen sehr hohen Anspruch an die Interpretationsfähigkeit und an die Erfahrung und das ist ein Ziel, das ZKI eben diese Erfahrung auch über die nächsten Jahre weiter aufzubauen.
Wie viele andere Gruppen wie das ZKI gibt es denn so weltweit, die ähnliche Dinge tun? Das ist nicht das einzige.
Ja, also mit dem Erfahrungsschatz gibt es vielleicht noch drei oder vier. In Europa gibt es noch Z-HIT, das ist eine Ausgliederung von der Uni Straßburg. Dann gibt es zum Beispiel noch UNO-SAT, das sind die Krisenkartierer der UN, die sitzen in Genf. Und dann sind über die letzten Jahre, ich sag mal noch zwei, drei dazugekommen, die sich aber eben diese Erfahrungen erst noch aufbauen müssen, was man auch definitiv heute noch an dem Service und an der Qualität der Produkte sieht. Aber grundsätzlich sieht man, dass dieser Bereich an Fahrt aufnimmt und dass da noch einige Spiele in der nächsten Zeit dazu kommen.
UNO-SAT, ZATID, da ist immer SAT mit drin. Ist denn der Satellit letztlich wirklich die einzige Quelle, aus der man solche Kriseninformationen beziehen kann? Oder gibt es auch noch andere Sensoren oder Fluggeräte, die zum Einsatz kommen bei Krisen?
Also Satellit ist in den meisten Namen tatsächlich vorhanden. Es ist aber so, dass jeder von diesen Partnern jede Art von, ich sag mal, luftgestützten Daten dann auch verarbeiten kann. Das heißt, wir haben für HIT genauso mit Drohnen-Daten gearbeitet. Wir arbeiten genauso mit Flugzeug- gestützten Systemen. Prinzipiell unterscheidet sich das Datenprodukt nicht großartig. Für uns ist die Analyse, die wir dann darauf berechnen, vergleichbar.
Wo kommen denn die Drohnen her?
Soweit ich weiß, war das dann das US-Militär, was dann drüber geflogen ist. Und die Daten aber dann sogar öffentlich bereitgestellt hat. Wobei man sich dann auch mal vor Augen halten muss, wie viel Datenkapazität das dann gebraucht hat. Wir haben uns dann sehr schnell darauf konzentriert, nur die drohenden Daten herunterzuladen, die wir tatsächlich brauchen. Aber insgesamt wurden für HIT bei uns mehrere Terabyte an Satellitendaten bearbeitet. Gesichtet, zum Teil dann eben auch analysiert. Wenn man sich das Beispiel Japan vor Augen führt, da wurden innerhalb von drei Wochen den japanischen Institutionen mehr als 1500 Satelliten-Szenen zur Verfügung gestellt. Und wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie viel Zeit das allein kostet, in die Daten reinzuschauen, sind sie brauchbar, habe ich da Bewirkung drin oder eben nicht, ist es überhaupt das Interessensgebiet, was ich gerade analysieren will oder nicht, kann man sich vorstellen, wie viel Zeit dann tatsächlich auch für verbraucht werden muss.
DLR verfügt ja auch über so eine kleine Flotte von Spezialflugzeugen, kommen die denn in Krisenfällen auch zum Einsatz?
Die Idee ist tatsächlich auch zu schauen, inwiefern das operationell verwendet werden kann. Im Moment ist es aber noch eher im Bereich Forschung angesiedelt, das Projekt SAFER hatte den charmanten Vorteil, dass man sowohl die operative als auch die Forschungskomponente hatte, sodass wir für einzelne Aktivierungen tatsächlich auch testen konnten, ob und wie satellitengestützte Daten und flugzeuggestützte Daten sich ergänzen können.
Das ist nicht so einfach, oder?
Ja, unser Ziel als Kathir ist natürlich, die Reaktionszeit und die Zeit zum ersten Krisenprodukt zu verkürzen. Da stoßen beide Systeme heute natürlich noch an ihre Grenzen. Für flugzeuggetragene Befliegung ist es natürlich dann auch schwierig, ad hoc zum Beispiel Überflugsgenehmigung, Bildaufnahmegenehmigung zu bekommen. Der Sensor muss natürlich eingebaut sein, der Einbau muss abgenommen sein, es muss einen Flugplan erstellt werden. Das sind alles Dinge, die auf der luftgetragenen Seite natürlich Zeit kosten, die heute noch nicht so weit operationalisiert sind, dass wir jetzt einfach bei der Flugbereitschaft anrufen und sagen, morgen früh Aufnahme über Ungarn.
Also tendenziell könnte man, der Vorteil ist ja, man kann sich dann aber auch Sensoren, die eben über Radar und optische Beobachtung hinausgehen, installieren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich habe jetzt selber kein Beispiel zur Hand, aber ist das überhaupt ein Szenario, oder ist das letztlich auch nur optische Beobachtung und Radarbeobachtung, von der wir sprechen?
Man kann es natürlich auch auf andere Sensoren übertragen, beispielsweise Hyperspektralsensoren. Man muss natürlich dann aber auch wieder schauen, welche sonstigen Eigenschaften der Sensor hat. Häufig ist es so, dass je mehr Bänder, je mehr Spektralbereiche ein Sensor abdeckt, desto gröber wird auch die Auflösung. Die Kombination, viele Bänder und hohe Auflösung, ist sehr selten bis gar nicht zu finden. Der Worldview ist ein optisches System, was aber noch andere Wellenlängen mitabdeckt, hat insgesamt acht Bänder. Mit dem kann man schon sehr viel anstellen, was Kriseninformationsanalyse angeht. Aber grundsätzlich kann man natürlich auch andere Wellenlängen ausnutzen, um Kriseninformation zu extrahieren.
Was ist mit Flugzeugen schon mal ausprobiert worden? Selbst wenn sich das noch im Forschungsbereich befindet?
Wir haben zum Beispiel für Ungarn, ich glaube es war letztes Jahr, für den Dampbruch an dem Alkaliwerk, wo der alkalische Schlamm dann durch mehrere Dörfer gerollt ist.
Der rote Schlamm.
Da haben wir dann sowohl mit höchstauflösenden Satelliten im optischen Bereich draufgehalten, als auch dann vom DLR aus eine Befliegung organisiert und sind drüber geflogen und haben dann eben geschaut, wo passt es schon, wo passt es nicht, wo müssen wir intern auch Prozesse noch optimieren, um genau diese Art der Anwendung auch für uns brauchbar zu machen in den nächsten Jahren. Für ein anderes Beispiel...
Ich meine, gab es da Erkenntnisse schon oder ist das alles noch ein bisschen offen? Könnte man da irgendwie herauslesen, dass jetzt so eine Beobachtung im Flugzeug mehr bringt?
Sie kann definitiv mehr bringen, weil ich zum Beispiel auch eine höhere Auflösung bekommen kann. Ich kann bis runter, wenn ich dann tief fliege, ich sag mal im Bereich 8 bis 10 cm gehen, was mir natürlich einen extremen hohen Grad an Detailinformation gibt. Natürlich habe ich dann auch wieder nur ein kleineres Gebiet, was ich abdecken kann. Dafür kann ich wieder spezieller auf einzelne Gebiete gehen. Ja, natürlich gibt es noch viele Dinge, die man da optimieren kann und auch optimieren muss, sei es von internen Kommunikationsketten, sei es vom Einbau des Systems im Moment. Hängen wir mehr an der Forschungsseite und an der, dass der Sensor für gewisse Zeiten überhaupt nur in diesem Flugzeug eingebaut ist. Das heißt, wir wissen, okay, ich sage mal, im Oktober ist zufällig der Sensor eingebaut. Wenn da so eine Aktivierung ist, dann können wir darauf relativ schnell zugreifen. Das heißt aber, in den elf anderen Monaten ist der halt nicht per se in diesem Flugzeug eingebaut. Und man müsste den erst einbauen und abnehmen lassen. Und das ist dann natürlich was, was mehrere Stunden dauert. Und da auf der anderen Seite die Satellitensysteme sich auch immer mehr auf die Schnelligkeit hintunen, heißt es mehrere Stunden Verlust. Da habe ich dann schon meine Satelliten-Szene normalerweise.
Das ist sozusagen ein Trend in der Erdbeobachtung, dass die Satelliten daraufhin optimiert werden, schnell einen bestimmten Bereich abdecken zu können. Weil das ist jetzt schon alles mehrfach fotografiert worden. Man hat gar nicht mehr so sehr den Hunger an Basismaterial, sondern es geht jetzt vor allem um die Änderungen, das Kurzfristige.
Ja, also man kann vielleicht exemplarisch zwei Missionen herausgreifen. Das eine ist der Envisat. Das ist so eine Art Flaggschiff. Das ist ein Riesenbus. Der hat mehrere Sensoren an Bord und eine relativ große Auflösung. Was heißt große Auflösung? Das ist ein großen Bildstreifen, den er abdeckt und ist allerdings in der Auflösung nicht allzu gut. Der fliegt dann einfach und ist relativ unflexibel. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel die Refleet-Eye-Konstellation sieht oder Kosmos-Geimer, das ist ein Radarsatellit, die bauen dann kleinere Systeme, kleinere Satelliten, aber schießen dafür mehrere in den Orbit, die dann zeitversetzt fliegen oder einen leicht anderen Orbit haben. Und damit erhöhe ich deutlich die Repetitionsrate. Also das heißt, Repetitionsrate heißt die Möglichkeit über einen bestimmten Ort, den ich mir auswähle, mehrfach rüber zu fliegen und eine schnellstmögliche Aufnahme zu bekommen. Und dahin, zumindest was Krisenanwendung geht, geht der Trend. Was gut für uns ist, es sind noch andere Dinge, die dann natürlich noch mitreinspielen ist. Wenn der Satellit aufgenommen hat, heißt das noch nicht zwingend, dass die Daten dann auch runterkommen. Das heißt, das Bodensegment muss natürlich auch dahingehend angepasst werden. Man muss vielleicht auf mehrere Bodenstationen auf der Welt verteilt zurückgreifen, um dann die Daten schnell runterzulinken auf die Erde und dann übers Internet vielleicht zu verteilen. Und möglichst schnell dann zu prozessieren und dann überhaupt erst zur Analyse zu bringen.
Also es gibt da noch so einiges, was in Bewegung ist. Man merkt auch, es ist halt auch wirklich eng mit der Forschung verbunden. Also einerseits hat man diese Dienstleistung, wo es um schnelle Reaktionen geht, schnelle Bereitstellung von Daten. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch ein permanenter Input und quasi auch eine permanente Anforderungsliste, die in die Forschungsbereiche des DLR wieder mit reingetragen werden.
Genau. Also im Moment profitieren wir extrem davon, dass wir eben genau diese beiden Seiten haben. Wir haben diese operative Komponente und wir haben die Forschungsseite. Und durch diesen Zyklus können wir uns relativ schnell auch an neue Entwicklungen dann eben anpassen. Insgesamt ist aber gerade diese Kriseninformation, auch wenn sie jetzt zehn Jahre, ich sag mal zehn Jahre Erfahrung schon vorweist, immer noch in einem Bereich, wo sie sich sehr stark entwickelt und die Technologien sich auch sehr schnell entwickeln. Von daher wird uns definitiv nicht langweilig.
Ja, ein schönes Schlusswort, wenn wir nicht noch irgendwas ganz Dringendes vergessen haben zu erwähnen. Meine Liste ist so ein bisschen abgehakt.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, ob wir ein großes Thema jetzt nicht angesprochen hätten.
Na ja, zur Not gibt es dann auch immer noch den Eintrag in unserem Blog raumzeitpodcast.de zu dieser Sendung, wo wir dann einerseits halt viele Links bieten über all das, wo wir hier gesprochen haben und wo auch Fragen zum Inhalt immer wieder gerne gesehen sind und auch unmöglich beantwortet werden.
Und die ZKI-Webseite gibt es beispielsweise auch, wo man noch Detailinformation und die Produkte zum Beispiel auch findet.
Und ja, da bleibt mir dann eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, vielen Dank Tobias. Für die Ausführung hier zum Zentrum für satellitengestützte Kriseninformation, ZKI, da wo die Daten herkommen, wenn mal wieder was ganz furchtbar schiefgelaufen ist auf diesem Planeten. Immerhin gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dann schnellstmöglich sich ein Bild zu verschaffen. Ja und auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war Ausgabe Nummer 25 und wie gewohnt, hier geht es dann weiter bei Raumzeit.